ABCs of AI M is for machine learning
machine learning or ml refers to a
program or system that trains a model
from input data the trained model can
make useful predictions from new data
drawn from the same distribution as the
one used to train the model which is
cool for so many reasons but it's also
cool because it simulates human learning
patterns to learn grow update and
develop Itself by continually assessing
data and identifying patterns based on
past outcomes and while ML and AI have
been used pretty interchangeably over
the past few years by a lot of people
machine learning is technically and
formally a subfield of AI which makes it
a perfect topic for